The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
There's a cute book called
The Point and the Line.
It was also made it
into an animated cartoon
that ends with the line, "To
the vector belongs the spoils."
And in this particular
course, we're
going to find that both the
traditional meaning of vector,
plus a modern meaning
of vector, plays
a very fundamental role
in the study of calculus
of several variables.
In fact, the modern definition
which we will ultimately
get to later in the
course, is the one
that will be of utmost
importance to us.
But in the meantime,
to better appreciate
what this will be like, we will
start with a more conventional
treatment of vectors.
Hopefully one fringe
benefit of this
will be to revisit what
vectors really are.
And to get on with this,
let me again point out
that we will be giving an
overview of what the unit is
all about in this lecture.
And the details
will again be left
to the supplementary notes,
the text, and the exercises.
I call this lecture
"'Arrow' Arithmetic."
And the reason for calling
this "'Arrow' Arithmetic"
hopefully will become
clear in a moment.
For the time being,
let's very quickly
review what a vector is.
I think most of us
know this, but just
to make sure there are
no misinterpretations,
a vector is any quantity which
depends on a direction as well
as a magnitude.
In other words,
a vector quantity
is one which in order
to specify uniquely,
we must tell what its
magnitude is-- its size;
we must tell what
direction it's in,
and finally something which
I call the sense wherein
I distinguish between the
same direction being traversed
in two different ways.
And perhaps the best
way to emphasize this
is in terms of a
one-dimensional analogy
that we have already
studied very, very early
in our mathematical careers.
I'm thinking of the idea of
visualizing signed numbers
in terms of the number line.
In other words, recall that
the number line was essentially
the x-axis.
And starting at some origin,
which we called say, 0,
we numbered 1, 2, et cetera
if we moved in the left-to-right
direction; and negative 1,
and negative 2, et cetera, if
we went from right to left.
In other words, even though
the direction of the x-axis
is still the same,
whether we go from left
to right or from
right to left, we
distinguish between the
two motions in terms of--
and this is what we mean
by the sense of a vector.
Some people say,
well the direction
includes the sense; I prefer to
have these two words dangling
around, so I can put them
at my disposal in any way
that I see fit.
But roughly speaking then,
this is all a vector is.
Now the idea is why arrows?
And the answer is-- and
here's a little ratio
I put down here-- an
arrow is to a vector
as a length is to a
scalar, whereby scalar, I
mean a number,
something which has
a magnitude, but no direction.
Remember when we
first started talking
about numerical
arithmetic, and talked
about graphing, and
visualizing numbers as lengths.
We picked the length to
represent the number,
and at that particular
time, since there
was only one degree of
freedom-- namely the x-axis--
we didn't emphasize direction.
But the idea is to carry
this analogy further.
What one does is when
one has a quantity which
is a vector, an arrow--
a traditional arrow--
a directed line segment
with a given sense.
The arrowhead
indicating the sense
is perhaps the
best way of drawing
what we mean by a vector.
Namely, I have just a
few random examples here.
Here's a collection of
things which are arrows.
They're line segments
in a given direction,
and the arrowhead indicates
a particular sense.
Notice by the way, that
the concept of a vector
does not depend on
an arrow, anymore
than the concept of a
number depends on a length.
The arrow is simply a convenient
geometric representation
for visualizing the vector.
Now hopefully, in
terms of the last unit,
you now have the feeling
that in mathematics,
to have an arithmetic,
one needs more
than a collection of objects.
That to have a structure,
one needs a collection
of objects together with
certain rules, and definitions,
and what have you.
And consequently, it
becomes rather mandatory
that somehow or other we be able
to categorize a pair of vectors
as to whether they shall
be called equal or not.
See, what shall we
mean by even saying
the two vectors shall be equal?
The equality of vectors.
And I claim the
following-- and let
me just state this
cold-bloodedly
until we come to
the end, and show
what we're driving at again.
To say that the vector A
equals the vector B means
that first of all, the magnitude
of A equals the magnitude of B.
By the way, again as in the
one-dimensional case-- when
we called the absolute
value the length--
we do the same thing
in terms of arrows.
We abbreviate the
magnitude of an arrow
by writing the absolute
value of the arrow.
In other words, the
absolute value of A
must equal the
absolute value of B.
Secondly, the arrow A must
be parallel to the arrow B.
And thirdly, A and B
must have the same sense.
And again to show
you what this is,
remember I said to you a moment
ago that the arrows are just
a convenient pictorial way
of representing a vector.
Let's observe that these
three properties here
juxtaposition very nicely with
these three properties here.
In other words, notice that
our definition of equality
of arrows captures exactly
what three ingredients go
into defining a vector.
Since all we're talking about
is magnitude, direction,
and sense, how can we
distinguish validly
between two vectors other
than in terms of magnitude,
direction, and sense.
OK?
By the way, let's be
very careful about this.
As long as the only way
that we can determine
the difference between
two vectors-- or arrows--
is in terms of their
magnitude, direction,
and sense, what this
means is that if you
have two vectors
which are parallel,
have the same
length-- two arrows,
same length, same direction,
and the same sense,
they must be called equal.
You see, in other
words, vectors do not
have to coincide to be equal.
Unlike the case
of straight lines.
In other words,
if I were to draw
a pair of parallel lines
here of equal length,
these would be called
different lines.
As soon as I do this these
are called equal arrows.
Why?
Because of our
definition of equality.
And if somebody says, "But I
don't like that definition,"
well this is the
same as the rule
that three strikes is
an out in baseball.
If somebody doesn't like
that rule, you say to them,
lookit, go and
play your own game,
and make as many strikes is an
out as you want, but don't call
that game baseball, because that
will confuse it with the game
that we're playing here,
which is different.
In other words, we make
up our rules to govern,
as I said in the last lecture,
what we believe to be reality.
And we believe that for how
we're going to use vectors
this is a very, very
natural definition.
And this is not the
first time in mathematics
that we've done
something like this.
Way back around the third
or fourth grade, here's
a little analogy, you get
used to saying 1/2 equals 3/6.
But obviously, the ordered
number pair 1 comma 2,
and 3 comma 6 look different.
It certainly makes a
difference physically
whether you cut a pie in
half and take one piece
or cut the pie into six
pieces and take three of them.
The physical process
is different.
The two fractions
don't look alike.
Why do we call them equal?
And it means that in terms of
what we want ratios to mean,
the number which you must
multiply by 2 to get 1,
is the same number that you
must multiply by 6 to get 3,
and consequently,
let's just keep
the equality in that sense.
Who cares whether they
look alike or not?
Let's call them
equal if they capture
the important characteristic.
And that's the way
this game is going
to be played all the time.
We will make up our
definitions to fit our mood,
and hopefully the mood that
suits me best will suit you
best, because I will try to pick
the reasons that you yourselves
would have liked to
have seen motivate
why we did the
things that we did
or that we're going to do here.
So let me talk about the
"addition" of vectors,
and let me put the word
"Addition" in quotation marks
here to indicate that all I mean
by the addition of vectors--
and perhaps I should still
say addition of arrows--
is I would like a rule that
tells me how to combine two
arrows to form another arrow.
Now again I can make up hundreds
of rules that tell me how,
for two given arrows, I'm
going to form a third arrow
from the given two.
But since our aim is to solve
problems of the real world,
why not pick a definition?
Why not pick a definition
that has already
been used in physics and
in other applications?
The thing called the resultant.
For example, given a
point O, and two forces,
represented as arrows, A and B,
acting at O, we have agreed--
or you may recall-- that
the resultant force is
the vector that
forms the diagonal
of the parallelogram which has
A and B as consecutive edges.
In other words, this vector
here was what in the old days
was called the resultant.
Because that has
such a nice usage,
I am going to call that
the sum of two vectors.
By the sum of two vectors
I mean what physically
used to be the resultant.
And a very nice way of
remembering the rule,
is remember that this vector
B is equal to this vector,
because this is a parallelogram.
These are equal in magnitude,
parallel in direction,
and have the same sense.
Notice that if I want
a quick recipe that
was convenient for adding two
vectors A and B, you say what?
Place the tail of the second
next to the head of the first,
and then draw the
vector-- the arrow--
that goes from the
tail of the first
to the head of the second.
And this will be the definition
of the addition of arrows.
And again, this is done in
much more detail in our written
material.
By the way, notice
again, a parallelism
between the structure of
vectors and the structure
of ordinary arithmetic.
In the same way that, given
two numbers, they have one sum,
but that a given
sum can be formed
by different
combinations of numbers,
that two given vectors, which
I call here x_1 and y_1,
give A as a sum, but notice
also that the vector A that is
sum of the vectors x_2 and y_2.
To generalize this,
if I picked any point
I wanted on the blackboard here,
and drew any two lines, one
going from the tail
of A to this point,
and one going from this point
to the head of A. Notice
that the resulting
two vectors here--
this vector plus this vector, by
definition of vector addition,
head to tail, from
the tail of the first
to the head of the second,
would still be the vector A.
In other words, in terms of the
diagram that I drew originally,
notice that A can be
written as x_1 plus y_1,
it can also be written
as x_2 plus y_2.
And notice again the
similarity of the structure
between arithmetic and vectors,
and notice the arbitrariness
with which we make
up our definitions.
We make up the definitions
to be our servant,
rather than for us to become
the servant of the subject.
We model the
definitions-- the truth
that we call-- after what we
believe happens in real life.
By the way, a very
convenient coordinate system
is our old friend the x and y
Cartesian coordinate system.
And the reason for
this is as follows.
Given any vector
A, we can always
assume that the vector
originates at the origin.
And the reason for
that is we've already
seen that two vectors
are equal if they
have the same magnitude,
direction, and sense
so wherever A was in the
plane of the blackboard,
we can shift it
parallel to itself,
so its tail starts
at the origin.
Let's assume that the
vector A, the arrow
A, which starts at the origin,
terminates at the point
a comma b.
Let i be a unit vector--
meaning a vector that
has one unit of length--
in the direction
of the positive x-axis.
Let j be a unit vector
which is in the direction
of the positive
y-axis, and our claim
is that our definition
of addition-- and you've
all seen this, I'm pretty sure.
Is that the vector A can
now be written as what?
A is equal to a*i plus b*j.
Where you see, if you've
seen this notation before
notice that in
terms of our game,
we are now forced to
introduce a new operation.
Because we claim in our
game that it's validity
that's important.
Validity, not truth.
If all I can use are the rules
of my game, for the first time,
what do I see here?
I see a number
multiplying the vector.
And if I don't have
rules of my game
that tell me what a number
multiplied by a vector means,
in terms of the logic
machine, the logic machine
can't do a thing to give
me inescapable conclusions.
Without assumptions, without
rules, there can be no proof.
So I must make up
a new definition,
and this definition is
called scalar multiplication.
And it's going to tell me how to
multiply a scalar-- a number--
by a vector.
If c is a number, and V
is a vector, by c times V,
I mean a vector, which
has-- I have to be careful,
see c could be a
negative number.
And since you think of
length as being positive,
I take the absolute
value of c just
to get the magnitude
of the number in here.
You see?
In other words, this
is a vector which
has the magnitude of c times
the magnitude of V. Meaning it's
c times as large as
V if c is positive,
and minus c times as large
as V if c is negative.
The same meaning of
absolute value as always.
For example, 2 times V would
be a vector whose magnitude
was twice that of the vector V.
Negative 2 times V would also
be a vector whose
magnitude is twice
that of V. The other
property is what?
I've just told the
magnitude, I also
have to give you the
direction and the sense.
c times v is in the same
direction as V. Minus 2 times
V, and plus 2 times V both
have the direction the V,
and both are what?
Twice the magnitude of V.
The only difference
between the minus is this.
That c times V has
the same sense.
Same sense as what?
Same sense as V,
if c is positive.
That means if c is negative,
it has the opposite sense.
In other words, for
example, 2 times V
has the same sense as V; minus
2V has the opposite sense of V.
But the important
point is this--
that vector arithmetic shares
many structural properties
of regular arithmetic.
That is very crucial
to understand.
I have a friend of
mine who doesn't
like teaching students
who are having
a few problems with
ordinary arithmetic,
and likes to teach
advanced courses.
And he often has
said that the trouble
with the average high
school curriculum
for the average student,
is that by the time
the student is through,
he knows three things:
If you see a sign, change it;
if you see a decimal point,
move it; and if you see
a fraction, invert it.
But he should have
gone one step further:
when the average
old-time engineering
students saw a vector, he
only knew one thing about it.
And the one thing
that he knew about it
was, if you see a vector,
break it down into components.
And after that, that was the
end of what they ever did
with vectors in the old days.
But the thing that is
crucial to understand here
is that we will use
vector arithmetic
in a far more powerful way.
We will use the structure
of vector arithmetic.
In the same way that
we formed algebra
from numerical
arithmetic, we will
form vector algebra,
and vector calculus
from vector arithmetic.
Let me give you an example.
We already know that
for two numbers a and b,
a plus b equals b plus a.
My claim is that from
our definition of arrows
and the like, it
should also be a rule
that for arrows, A plus
B should equal B plus A.
Or, for numbers, we already
know that A plus B plus C equals
A plus B plus C.
That doesn't look right.
By the way, what I wrote
there wasn't false,
it was certainly true.
But it was too trivially true.
I guess what I wanted
to emphasize here
was that the voice inflection
made no difference.
Now again, notice how we
verify the rules of the game.
I have to make up rules that
I will call basic truths.
Those rules-- or
axioms-- will be
modeled after what I believe
to be true in reality.
Now, notice in reality
I've formed this whole idea
in terms of what?
Arrows.
I defined what addition meant.
Let's take a look and
see what A plus B means.
If this is the vector A, and
this is the vector B, then
what is the vector A plus B?
By definition of how
you add two vectors,
this vector here would be A
plus B. On the other hand,
I could take the vector
A, which is down here,
move it parallel to itself
so it originates here,
mark it off the same length.
This is still the vector A.
If I now draw the arrow
that goes from the tail of B
to the head of A,
what vector is this?
Well by definition,
it's B plus A.
How are B plus A and
A plus B related?
They are opposite sides
of a parallelogram,
therefore they have the same
magnitude, and same direction.
And the picture shows us that
they have the same sense.
Since this is true
in the picture,
why not claim that
one of the rules
of our game of
vector arithmetic--
even though legally you
shouldn't use pictures,
but pictures do give
us the motivation.
Why not say, OK,
we'll accept the rule
that A plus B
equals B plus A. How
about our second rule over here?
Let's take three vectors.
Let me take A over here,
let me put B over here,
and let me put C over here.
And I hope that this will
come out legible enough
for all of us to see.
I claim on the one hand
that I can think of A plus B
plus C in two different ways.
In other words, to use the way
that says A plus (B plus C)
from this diagram, how do
I get the vector B plus C?
Since B and C are lined up
in the right position head
to tail, the vector
B plus C is the one
that goes from the tail
of B to the head of C.
So I call this vector B plus C.
Now, what is A plus (B plus C)?
It's this vector plus this one.
In other words, this
vector here could
be labeled A plus (B plus C).
On the other hand, what
is the vector A plus B?
A plus B is this vector.
Because it goes from the
tail of A to the head of B
and consequently,
(A plus B) plus
C is the vector that goes
from the tail of A plus B
to the head of C. In other
words, what vector is that?
It's this vector, but
what name does that have?
We just saw.
That's (A plus B) plus
C. And now we see what?
We have two different
names for the same arrow.
In particular then, these two
different names represent what?
Two arrows which have the
same magnitude, sense,
and direction, and
therefore they're equal.
And that's why we make
up rules like this.
And by the way, the
analogy continues on,
and this is done in much
more detail in our notes,
but I just thought I would
like to say a few more
words in general.
For example, one talks
about the zero vector.
And I write that with a
0 with an arrow over it,
to indicate the zero arrow.
Maybe your intuition tells you
that the zero vector should
somehow be connected
with a zero number,
but the point that
I want to drive at
is an analogy to what we did
in the previous lecture, when
we showed why b to the 0
has to be defined to be 1.
The idea is that an
ordinary arithmetic, what
is the beauty of the number 0?
The beauty of the numbers 0 is
that with respect to addition,
it does not change the
identity of any number.
Any number plus 0 is
that number back again.
In particular then, why not keep
the same structure for vectors?
And it's our choice to make.
We would like to say OK, let's
define the zero vector to be
such that if A is
any other vector,
A plus 0 will still
be A. Well let's
get an idea of what that means.
Let B denote the magnitude
of the zero vector.
What this means is what?
How do I add 0 to A?
I start with the vector
A, and it originates here.
And terminates at the point p.
Now how do I add
on the zero vector?
The zero vector, all I know
is it's going to start at P,
and be length b.
So the surest
thing I can say is,
lookit, let me draw a circle
centered at P, with the radius
equal to b.
In other words the
radius of this circle
here, the radius of
this circle is b.
All I know is that whatever
the zero vector is,
if its magnitude is b, the zero
vector must originated at P,
and terminate someplace
on this circle.
Because that's the locus
of all vectors of length b
which originate at P.
For the sake of argument,
let's say that the zero vector
happens to be PQ.
Then A plus 0 is the vector
that goes from this point to Q.
But A plus 0 must be A.
And since A and A plus 0
originate at the same
point, the only way
they can have the same
magnitude, direction,
and sense, is that
they must coincide.
In other words, in
particular, P must equal Q.
And as soon as P equals Q, the
magnitude of the zero vector
must be the number 0.
In other words, in terms of
our game structure again,
if we want this
structural to be obeyed,
and again I must emphasize this:
The choice is ours to make.
But if we want the
structural rule to be obeyed,
we must define the zero
vector to be the vector which
has zero magnitude.
As natural as it
seems, that's not
the real reason for doing it.
We do it because it gives us
the structure that we want.
The same is true, for example,
about the additive inverse.
Remember in ordinary
arithmetic, the additive inverse
meant what?
The number that must be
added to the given number
to give the zero number.
Or the number 0.
In vectors, we should
define negative A
to be the vector
which when added to A
gives the zero vector.
Well, lookit, any
vector that I add to A--
let me call that
vector B. Any vector
that I add to A-- which I call
A plus B-- looks like this.
Well what is the only
way that the vector A
plus B can be the zero vector?
Well the zero vector
has no length.
That means the only
way that's possible
is if the tail of
A plus B coincides
with the head of A plus B. And
the only way that can happen,
is if B terminates right here.
In other words, the vector
that we call negative A
is going to be the vector
which has the same magnitude
and direction as A,
but the opposite sense.
And we're not saying
it's self evident.
All we're saying
is look-- if you
want this structural
property to be true,
you have no choice but to
define negative A to be
the vector which has the same
magnitude and direction as A,
but the opposite sense.
And by the way, as
soon as you do that,
there are no more guessing
games involved in how
you subtract two vectors.
For, just in the same
way that we did it
in ordinary arithmetic, we
define the difference of two
vectors A minus B
to mean the vector
A added to the vector negative
B. And what is negative B?
The vector which just has the
opposite sense of the vector
B. And again, these
computational details
are left to the notes,
and to the exercises.
But the main
overview that I want
you to get from this
lecture is to see
that there are more to
vectors than dividing them up
into components.
That there is an
arithmetic imposed on them,
and that arithmetic
that's impose on vectors
is just as real
as the arithmetic
of the ordinary real numbers.
And to reinforce this,
in our next lesson,
we will talk about vectors in
three-dimensional space, where
the geometry becomes
tougher, but the structure
remains exactly the same.
But until next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses, by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.